hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander we're gonna check out a video
from all-time ten ten actors who started
out in porn i think Sally's on this list
it would make sense
excuse me I'm not a celebrity yet well
you weren't something yeah but that
doesn't negate the fact that you start
off and put you know what let's stop it
let's stop it your videos are not even
featured on the good websites
it's like page 8 of Google I got five
against their featured Cameron Diaz
Adie photo shoot cheese no oh the way I
got you like we'll start with the video
blinded Matt LeBlanc no way started the
erotic series red Shoe Diaries Wow so
it's okay to go on a porn and one
episode launches you secretary the
leader has sex with her in elevator nice
Marilyn Monroe that's a pretty obvious
one my Road did a nude photo shoot for
just $50 1949 about of my four years
later appear in the centerfold of
Playboy which helped law firm playboy
become I
sasha grey she's considered an actress
now former porn star became a serious
acting finger-licking good
and acting alongside alive what role
david Ducati x-files murder starred in
the sophomore TV show red shoes to her
as well playing a man who loves sex
stories ironically in 2008 the company
checked himself into rehab for sex
addiction
it's judgemental number five John and I
would love to see John dressed 1 sets
before he played Don Draper away $200 a
day working skinemax an hour 25 $250,000
per man
someone should look like as a struggling
24-year all these artists in like the
party I'm Kitty and stunts
so when was the need a bus shelter
recently the road has nobody's under
$200 and there's your Schwarzenegger
compliment if you want removed before
terminator Arnie was a model for inque
magazine really engaged in the 1970
issue of after-dark e past nude for the
feature muscle-bound World War II are
neat windows are Jackie Chan thanks
Timmy side we started Hong Kong for all
the families a rickshaw driver who has
an affair with a married woman
what its chance only film without a
fight sequence I had no idea he's like
one of my heroes Helen Mirren my near
plays a Roman Empress and naughty
courtesan in the porno epic Caligula the
film was being so graphic and censure
says banned in Canada Iceland sweet Wow
hi YouTube that was a top 10 okay
started in the more there was quite a
few shopping ones an edge-on donation
was another what's the main one yeah
Cameron Diaz Jackie Chan yeah Josh and
championed fair play to go stop some
other rights you have a saw some way
yeah
so what we're know from you guys is of
which of the list would you most
surprised that which was your most
shocked at let us know in the comments
below on and join in kakeland yeah if
you enjoyed this video check out top 10
porn searches for men and women is
linked inside under the description and
yeah I actually like swallows ready
going on in the middle of video
professionals okay
Wow so I guess to answer their question
the shocking one for me
I mean before this video started I was
talking to Sally and her boyfriend big
dick Nick about you know like who they
thought it was and they said Jackie Chan
was probably on the list I thought that
was like some rumor they believed
shocking that's [ __ ] crazy
I've read the book I am Jackie Chan his
autobiography never mentioned it never
covered it I don't think I would have
mentioned it either
wouldn't be my proudest moment
hmm who's Nick talking to Nick we're
trying to film Nick root room film but
boyfriend's know they don't respect the
art of reactions they don't understand
how microphones luck either
yeah bet it picks up sound I paid $250
for this microphone it echoes hey that
goes Nick Nick Cameron Diaz when she was
19 did a porno Kevin not surprising I
gotta find it yeah but then she tried
doing sex tape to try to be more
relevant and that was awful be whatever
this woman II think if she'd had like
you know experience in a porno that
would be good even better maybe I why
what do you care about her recent career
I just want to watch this porno that
Cameron Diaz is in when she was 19 he
picked him up she still looks good for
her age yeah and Wow um I can only
imagine 19 year old Cameron Diaz I'm
gonna jerk it to that angel that's right
charlie
jerking off to your angel that's awesome
cuz she never does nudity in actual
movie I thought if you did porn away
like you couldn't ever be anything
serious are you talking about they just
listed and I have time that I introduced
all this no I know that's why I'm like
blacklisted because when I was single I
was like hey I might try to add some
porn right and then everyone was like
yeah but you'll never have an actual
career after that and I thought no
you're wrong there must be some people
so this list is inspiring
now the Blanc Joey from friends pretty
it's funny because he's such a like a
sex pervert is Madeleine as a Joey and
and now it it intertwines well with his
image that's pretty cool that he was
actually I would like to see that too
from a observational standpoint right so
you just be sitting there Walter
yeah I wouldn't actually touch myself to
it hey whatever you do hmm
just remember God's watching I'm
surprised they put Sasha Grey on this
list because she's not like a huge
well-respected actor or something yeah
sasha grey I remember the first time I
ever saw Sasha Grey it wasn't in a porno
it was on the Tyra Banks Show yeah and
she was like 19 at the time and she had
already done like gangbang videos and
like orgies and so I she did a bunch of
crazy videos I saw my shoes doing news
yeah and she was like looking at as work
as an actress and she was looking at it
as just a career and then Tyra was
totally judging the [ __ ] at her but then
like a week later she brought on someone
from the bunny ranch which is a legal
whorehouse and she was like hey this is
awesome you're fun and everything but
Tyra Banks you're a hypocrite but
saucier great um I hope your career gets
better you are she's actually I saw her
entourage she played herself but for
several episodes but she's pretty good
and yeah yeah definitely jerkin her a
few times uh thank you for watching this
video we're not done Sylvester Stallone
and Arnold Schwarzenegger two of the
most legendary action icons of all time
plus Jackie Chan three Hey you know what
it kind of makes sense if they have a
kick-ass look and body like why not why
not use it I gotta watch those videos
because I want to see if you know you
imagine Stallone Schwarzenegger and how
embarrassing would it be if they just
had like a really small penis I gotta
see if it's big or not makes fair enough
yeah yeah [ __ ] me day but do come on
your base come on me if you want to live
and Helen Mirren she's hella serious
actors I know she's an Oscar winner
Helen Mirren is like the hottest elderly
lady I've ever seen
I saw a bikini photo from People
magazine
I was like I'd have to say um Julie
Andrews is the hottest older woman I've
ever seen it was pretty good argue no no
no I'm saying she's good-looking I'm
just saying that Helen Mirren if I was
in a position where I had to like bone
one of these older woman I choose the
Mirren and I would definitely take a
Viagra you know those old people can go
for long periods of time now because of
those pills for Viagra yeah you've heard
of viagra right yes
isn't your boyfriend use it do you use
bad a good Nick I did the touch I'm an
idiot sorry that's active it just means
I'm so odd you know how to make yourself
look good anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out
salamander Sally's channel fun variety
on there you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine periscope and
let's do a shout out
logan armstrong struck oh yeah he's a
total loser then yeah hey I'm a big fan
of the show I started watching you since
you uploaded your brick mansions trailer
reaction long time ago I've been
watching almost every day ever since
that reaction my main goal is to become
a filmmaker and a shout out would help
my upcoming short film get some
recognition and help my dream my YouTube
account is mouth macaque mall ma ul Mik
Hawk Hawk make hawk
listen man I can't promote you because I
can't find your [ __ ] channel you
spelled it for me I spelled it for the
audience you know what man this is not
helping dude I need to be able to
promote you properly so you can pursue
your dreams of being a successful
filmmaker
the conflict of [ __ ] oh here it is
there's a cat on the thumbnail I'm not
gonna watch this right now if there's
any advice I could give you its remember
that 95% of people who go into the film
industry naked they are mainly
successful people in the film industry
it's one of the most guaranteed
businesses out there the you can be
successful 95% rate or you can just go
into porn
that is included in what I am talking
about it's mainly porn anyone who does
porn makes a good paycheck Mall make
Hawk um I think you and I should team up
in a porno not actually with each other
with a girl I think this is really gonna
help promote him yeah I mean his films
called the conflict of [ __ ] lord
knows he likes them anal